In Israel, the people who don't have
an immediate connection
to Jews in the diaspora
do not understand the meaning
of this connection.
Sharona Shir Zablodovsky,
how are you?
Good. How are you?
Fantastic. Fantastic.
This next 20 minutes,
there's a lot of topics to cover.
The primary one and the center of them
is the Jewish diaspora
and Israeli nature.
But your work spans across
nonprofit organizations, beyond that.
And I would love to start
with your journey,
and where you come from,
and how you end up
being such an advocate
and a proactive member
of the group that's
trying to work through
the complicated nature
of the Jewish people.
So, Sharona,
before we get to that complicated topic,
I'd love to start off
with who you are
going back all the way to
when you were getting your bachelors
and your masters.
So, I think that the turning point for me
was after a few years
that I worked in the Israel Film Fund,
and I worked in the
National Theatre of Habima,
and I had like this glamorous
positions
in very cool places.
And it was fun, but it wasn't my place.
And it didn't feel like the right match.
So, I thought to myself after graduation,
so, I studied this public policy
and it was very inspiring.
But I said to myself,
something has to change.
Like my track wasn't the track.
So, I just decided,
okay, now I'm going to act differently.
I didn't know what I'm going to do.
I didn't know what
I'm going to learn.
But I understood that I have to go
and just jump in the water
and see how it goes.
So, one morning in the summer,
I sat here in Tel Aviv
in the center of Tel Aviv
and drank coffee near my house,
and I saw an article about
the education system in Israel.
And I said to myself,
okay, I want to work in something
with impact,
I want to do something meaningful.
I'm very connected to values
in the nonprofit world.
Let's see, what can I do.
So, one article talked about
the education, and it was like a table
of all the organizations that work
in field of insource and outsourcing
for children of all ages.
And I saw
that there is a lot of funding
for this field
and it's very impactful.
Right.
And I said to myself,
okay, if there is so many resources,
I can find work, right?
Because I wanted to step and progress
in my experience
and work in the workspace.
And I said,
okay, let's call all these organizations
and I will find work.
I was very naive,
it's very cute, by the way.
But things turned differently.
So, I started calling all these places
and started checking
and trying to find work.
And I didn't find work.
And one place, by the way,
got back to me.
I went to an interview
and they offered me a very low salary.
And I said,
okay, this is not a place for me.
I will not take
the first option that I have.
So, time goes by.
I understood that
I think my passion is more of,
on formal education.
And so, I started checking.
By the way,
what was it about education
that you are so infatuated with
at that moment?
So, were you thinking about it
for a while?
Were you just,
all of a sudden,
you were reading the article
and you were like,
oh, okay, there's this whole world here
that I've yet to explore
that makes a lot of sense to me?
What was it
that really attracted you to that field?
I think, mostly,
I understood that
there are two million kids in Israel
that goes to learn
in the educational system,
and it's when you want to affect society
and how it will build
and the future of Israel,
I think that it's the most powerful tool
because everybody
has to go to school.
Everybody.
It doesn't matter which sector you are.
So, if you want to impact,
two million kids,
I think it's very impressive.
Right.
So, I think that,
a parallel that I like to make here,
and I get to talk
to quite a few entrepreneurs
that are also,
they are describing the way
that they reach their idea
and their, eventually, company is that,
this is a very bottoms-up approach.
You're looking at what's happening.
Okay. So, we have two million kids.
What's common for these two million kids?
They're all going to school.
On the other hand,
I'm trying to figure out
how I can make a positive impact
on the state of Israel as a whole.
And given that there's two million kids
going to school,
this is a very direct way
of pretty much impacting
every single person
that's going to grow into this
greater generation
that's going to be in the workforce.
Right?
If you impact the education sphere today,
you're actually impacting
the workforce in five to 10 years.
And it has a big
butterfly effect moving forwards.
And for me, that makes me curious about,
you know, how do people
identify key areas
that they can have a positive impact.
And I'm thinking about that for myself
as I'm going to go
into my own ventures one day.
But I just want to set that aside,
because that's one of the things
that I'm truly passionate about
in uncovering through this show.
Yeah. So, I think that
when I realized the capacity
that is impacted, and as you mentioned,
it's the future of Israel
at the end of the day,
like each country.
So, what I found out
during seeking for a work,
not for anything,
I didn't even know about
the existence of the
entrepreneurship world.
I wasn't aware of that at all.
Because I had this DNA of nonprofit,
I thought, okay, life,
I had like this set of beliefs
that life is A, B, C,
and that's how it goes.
But when I decided to act differently,
I had like different opportunities.
So, I started to seek for each place,
meet ups, places, lectures,
everything that is designed
or in this content.
So, I started going
and I started asking people
and I met people,
and I just wanted to work by the way.
I didn't have any intention to,
to do anything
that is like building
or having recreation.
None of that.
But the thing is,
that the more people that I came across,
the more I understood that the content
is getting out of the education ministry.
And that means that kids
are learning different values
in different areas in Israel,
which means,
if kids are brought up
in a more developed,
more wealthy surrounding,
they will have more opportunities.
And when I was growing up,
it wasn't like that.
It was public school.
Everybody went to the same school,
same values,
same opportunities.
So, you have the same cards.
Yeah.
So, in a nine million population,
we're not a big country.
But still it's a game changer
when you have more open opportunities
as a child.
So, how does that then translate
to your passion of the Jewish diaspora
and the Israeli people?
Because until now we're talking about
internally within the state of Israel
how education is impacting the kids
growing up in Israel.
How do you then become involved
with this whole other
industry or ecosystem
that is not necessarily
directly correlated with the education
within Israel?
No.
Well, by chance,
I got into the discourse
of Israel diaspora relationship.
I got into this amazing opportunity
through AJC
and I'm very grateful for that.
I went on a delegation
to DC at 2016.
And I always was fascinated
by this relationship.
And personally,
I have a family in the US,
but I never, it was by the way,
the first time that I was in the US,
and until I wasn't there
I didn't understood
how meaningful it was,
even though I have family here.
So, I think that
the connection
between education
and the Jewish diaspora,
Israeli diaspora relationship,
combines that,
for me now,
as reflecting back,
I think that what we need in society
in Israel is to learn about our history.
And the history of, by the way,
all diaspora, not only American Jews.
Okay?
Because there was a turning point.
Israel was established.
It was a race
to build a new country,
which is the wonder itself.
Right.
That's another topic.
And we went to different routes.
Different like,
challenges in life.
Because we're a majority,
Jewish diaspora is minority,
so we have a lot of things
that are very different.
But the same,
because we have same history,
same values,
we share a lot of things together.
So, I think that now,
looking back, I think,
if local leadership would embrace
the studies of the holistic situation
and also learning
about the streams in Judaism,
it will make us stronger
as a global nation.
And I think it will be very beneficial
for Israelis in general.
Because I think that personally,
Israeli people who don't have
an immediate connection
to Jews in the diaspora
do not understand the meaning
of this connection.
So, I love to provide
a little bit more context
to both my Israeli friends
who don't necessarily have
that direct connection,
or to my American-Jewish friends
would don't necessarily have
that connection,
or to anybody in the world
that's listening
that doesn't necessarily know
about this interesting situation
that we're caught up in.
So, can you give me
a little bit of context.
How many Israelis are there in Israel?
How many Jews are there
outside of Israel?
Where are they located around the world?
And why aren't everybody
just coming into Israel?
Or, why is there even an issue?
Why is it a problem that they're there
and we're here?
Okay. So, in Israel,
where about seven million,
give or take something like that.
In the US, it's somewhere around,
as far as I know, today,
five million, maybe five and a half.
It's like, it's very similar capacity,
like Israel
and the North American community.
In general,
there is a small community in Russia,
there are in Latin America communities.
So, it's more of the same total.
I think Jews around the world
total minority of like 40 million
or something like that.
It's like very, very small nation.
I think that
the situation now,
and I'm very passionate,
as you mentioned about it,
I think that,
local leadership is not dealing
with this situation.
Of course, we have the covid now,
the coronavirus is like
questioning everything.
It's like a game changer
and we have to adapt to
and solve the problems
regarding health issues,
regarding the economics,
regarding everything.
But there is a turning point that if
the policy making,
let's say leaders will not take
the situation to their own hands here,
I think that it will be very, very,
the circumstances could
be very, very bad.
So, I'm still to understand
what is the issue?
So, you know,
on one level, yes, I think that
obviously Jews around the world,
most of them
are big supporters of Israel.
They are part of the miracle
of the nation of Israel.
But why is there a problem today
that there are
five and a half million Jews in the US?
Some are Latin America, some in Russia,
some in Israel.
I mean, Israel is pretty dense, right?
I mean, there's a lot of people here
crowded in the streets.
So, we don't necessarily have room
to have, you know, 17 million people
in Israel right now.
What is the issue right now?
And what is the absolute best vision
or the ideal situation that you think
we should strive for
if what we have now is not ideal?
I think, first of all,
I don't think that
everybody should dwell here.
I don't call this, like we're thinking,
I think that you can be Zionist
and live abroad wherever you like,
because eventually Israel is the home
spiritually and physically
for the Jewish nation.
So, it doesn't matter where you live
you know.
It's the home that
the Jewish people yearn for
like 2000 years.
So, I think that everybody
can leverage from the fact that
we have this big presence.
The main gap
is because of the streams.
In the last century, give or so,
they became a few streams in Judaism
which has different aspects to them.
And I think that's the main problem.
Because the different streams
want to go their way.
Like in Israel,
most of Israel is belonging
to the orthodoxy,
and Judaism in the diaspora
is conservative,
is a reform and also orthodox.
So, the streams there are different
and we are majority,
Jewish diaspora are minority.
They have different challenges in life.
So, we as Israeli don't know that
because we're used to,
okay, it's nothing.
It's a different game.
Of course.
So, I think that mainly,
and there is legislation now
and the Knesset
of the Ministry of Diaspora,
and another MK
that is dealing with opening
a setting of direct consulting
between the Knesset
and the Jews in the diaspora leaders.
And it haven't, it doesn't exist.
And I have to say,
I'm very surprised that it doesn't exist
until today because we belong
to the same nation.
Of course, that this legislation
is not aimed to interfere in sovereignty
because people who are not
citizens in Israel cannot vote,
therefore cannot decide
about security issues.
But on matters,
and I think it's very, very important,
and by the way
I have to say and emphasize,
this is my own personal opinion
that it's very important
to have a discourse.
Even though you might not,
the streams, I refer,
even if the streams will not agree,
they have to talk, they have to talk.
So, because there is a lack
of communication and lack of knowledge,
by the way, here and abroad,
and in the diaspora,
I think that there is like
misunderstanding.
Because how we can get along?
Like this gap is based on that.
And if we open a channel
and accept one another, the streams,
it will be easier
to provide everybody a future
because we have still the same goals.
We still belong to the same nation,
even though it expresses
different otherwise.
Like the streams have different,
like day to day,
they see things differently.
But we have seen, unfortunately,
the price.
The price is heavy
for the Jewish people
and the last century paid,
and we don't want to go back there.
Sharona, I have to say,
I think that what you're saying
is absolutely right.
I think that the miscommunication,
and the lack of communication,
or the lack of effort
to really understand
and step into the shoes of the other.
And obviously, we know that Israeli Jews,
they act a little differently
than perhaps
American Jews or Latin American Jews.
Cultural reasons,
just like I as an Israeli act differently
from a lot of my friends
at Stanford that are American.
And we accept that.
And the difference is that,
that perhaps there,
since I'm situated there,
I get to explain myself a lot.
My directness and my chutzpah
sometimes, may come across insulting.
And then I have a chance to explain
the misunderstanding.
And I'm personally very involved
with a fund called the J-Ventures
with Oded Hermoni,
which I'm sure that, you know,
because one of the goals of this fund
is to connect the Israeli Jews
and the diaspora Jews.
And I believe that he also took part
in one of the programs that you did.
And it's been
a very rewarding experience
working with investors
and entrepreneurs and executives,
both from Israel and from Latin America
and Russia and the US
and all around the world.
So, I'm definitely,
I understand the urgency
of what you're saying
and the importance of it.
And I think that,
and I get to enjoy
bridging that gap on a daily basis.
But, Sharona, before we have to end,
I want to thank you
for being generous with your time
and for joining me here.
And I have to ask for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
I think that the three words
that will describe me is perseverance
and optimism
and learning.
I think it's very important
for evolving and for growing.
I love it.
Sharona, thank you very much.
This is great.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
You too. Bye.